trevor ballard well tom this is where
when you have depth in your starting
rotation and you give a game away like
the red did yesterday you find some
solace in running out a guy who can be a
stopper two and two one good room and
that strike three called and boy this
cincinnati starting rotation jonathan
scott
swing and a miss and that's back-to-back
strikeouts on that breaking ball and now
to miguel cabrera and there's a rocket
van bieber able to get to it and will
throw out cabrera sharply hit ball but a
one two three opening inning for trevor
starting at four
the tigers 27 years young grew up in
madison mississippi
pitched collegiately at the university
of alabama is spencer turnbull here's
winker here's the 2-2
tried to check
he sure did he did here's eugenio suarez
here's the one-two
okay that's 11-pitch inning for spencer
turnbull
harold castro
blew him away with a fastball that was
up and away from him and that's already
three strikeouts through the first six
batters for trevor bauer one ball and
two strikes on reyes and bauer the paws
and here it comes
got him swinging
bauer with four punch outs and the beat
goes on for this red starting rotation
racing grinders lead off the third
there's the fifth strikeout of the game
by trevor bauer
all the reds pitchers have really thrown
a lot of fastballs to nico
here's the 2-1
good connects
that's deep to right center field
home run for nico goodrum
a solo blast his third of his career
against bauer and the tigers are on the
board first and with two away here's
suarez
we've played three
tigers leading one-nothing
bauer stays right out on cj
crone six strikeouts now for trevor
bauer two away
i mean their fans just banging down the
doors to try and get in this place he
gets castillanos van meter and akiyama
here in the fourth
second time that he struck out
castellanos here today
van meter sends one toward kristen
stewart plenty of room
two up and two down now the payoff
turnbull wins that battle another punch
out for turnbull
very tight one nothing ball game
because here strike three called
one grinder
struck him out and that's exactly what
you called for
that's 95 gas right there the 3-2 on
jones
got him and looking on a fastball at 98
miles per hour from trevor bauer
to kurt casalett
this one rifled to center
that is blasted jones drifting back and
he's got it right at the wall
jacoby jones put that one on the
highlight reel oh my i loved it he
turned his back to the ball knowing he
had to get back to the
warning track or the fence
and he picked it up again that's a hard
thing to do and he just runs it down
stays with it a tremendous
effort catch right there by jacoby jones
there's a little pop-up in the shallow
right this has a chance to fall and it
will
so that's the first hit of the year for
jesse winker
and jankowski running all the way with
two away advances on to third so now a
big chance for joey votto
they're gonna give him a shot at it and
he may have dropped one in there yes he
did just a little floater into right
center field and vado has tied the game
with a two-out knock
1-1 affair and winker on to third
big-time delivery by bottom and two on
nicholas
strikeout number eight the biggest of
the afternoon for turnbull
oh and two on scope
well he got the strikeout a pitch later
2-2
and this time cabrera called out on
strikes he didn't like it
[Applause]
all right here's trevor bauer in a 1-1
game he has struck out
12.
and that is strikeout number 13 for
trevor bauer i mean is there any way to
be ready for that pitch
look at
goofing around right there david bell is
coming out to take him out of the game
oh and he took a little crow off like he
was going to throw the ball over the
center field wall which he did last year
punched out 13 batters in six and a
third allowed two hits one walking away
cj crone
[Applause]
goes the other way deep to right
get going
good
how about that
a two-run bomb
and cj crone has surged the tigers back
in front
pretty impressive
you see the power of both sides of the
field this one
goes out to right field but what a
clutch hit it was friends with a
fighting chance here in the bottom of
the ninth inning
there's a drive into right center field
and this ball will find the gap up and
over the wall ground will double by
galves so the tying run will indeed come
in the plate
aquino a looper into left center field
it's going to fall a hit
and he will go into second base with a
double driving in a run and don't look
now the reds have the
tying run at second base and the winning
run coming to the plate number nine
hitter casalli coming up
high fly ball this
will be caught and aquino's tagging up
here comes the throw it's way off line
he'll get to third anyway
saw three absolute nasty fastballs from
gregory soto in his last at-bat so
[Applause]
on the ground a second here it is good
room on the turn the tigers win it
since he threatens in the ninth
but the double play started by scope
turns them aside